so what is today is Friday tomorrow
Saturday how do we know that by Sun
setting sun rising so everything's
connected in the sun you have a teeth in
your mouth before you eat what you do
you chew you understand you have your
eyes above not below because when you
walk you can see you see that's why in
the Quran in in our holy book Allah told
us to look at the creation and to look
at our own eles so there's a verse in
the Quran I will say in Arabic and
translator for you Allah
[Music]
said the meaning of the verse Allah said
upon the Earth there's a signs for
Allah's existence and he should be wored
alone and within in yourselves you know
your heart is like a
machine you see yeah that can't come
that is impossible illogical irrational
to come randomly right you understand
because you can see this universe is
either product of knowledge or no
knowledge and we can see the
manifestation of God's knowledge within
the
creation you know you and I look the
animals look at the trees every the
season you
know the winter then then you have
spring then a summer you know
everything's
connected so if this the case the cre
this universe must have a
Creator and that Creator is all powerful
knowledgeable and wise like we can see
and shows you the Creator is merciful
too how if we came from a blind matter
where do we get Mercy from blind matter
doesn't have mercy how blind matter is
going to give you something doesn't have
doesn't possess you see likewise the
feelings that we have our Consciousness
you know this cannot be explained by
scientists you know and if I can ask
what's the difference between Allah and
for example the Christian Creator my dad
beli in that's a good question we as a
Muslims we believe in Jesus we believe
in
Moses we believe in Abraham we believe
in all of them the difference between us
and the Christians the Christians start
adding to one God two Gods okay they
start believing the Son and the Holy
Spirit yeah but we believe the the
Christian they call him the father this
the father that they call the father we
call him God Allah you know like the
Jewish people they believed in God
they you know in different languages so
we believe in the same God however the
previous scriptures was corrupted like
the Romans the Romans are pagans so they
start corrupting the teaching of Jesus
before them likewise the Jewish people
the Jewish people who believe in Moses
like I said we believe in Abraham but we
believe that the scripture was corrupted
too and when it comes to the Quran you
might say what how come the Quran was
not corrupted we look to the Quran one
of the Miracles of the Quran Allah told
us he made it easy for people to
memorize
it we have made Quran easy to be
memorized now if the Muslims and Jewish
people and the Christians decides to
burn their scriptures say you know what
let us burn our scriptures the only
scripture remain with us is the Quran cu
the Quran it has been memorized by 100
million of Muslims word for word letter
for letter everyone knows the
Quran Muslims that know it not every
Muslim but every Muslim knows at least
at least two chapters by heart w at
least and that's the Quran yes you know
one of the Mir of the Quran that's the
sign of the Quran there's many Muslims
who doesn't not speak Arabic language
and they memorize the Quran all of it
word for word letter for letter in
Arabic
language imagine you speak SP Spanish
correct yeah I speak Spanish sorry yeah
you can come this side
can you catch us both from this side
yeah yeah cuz imagine all of us here we
memorize
uh can I get the book please one second
IM imagine all of us here we memorize
this book in
Chinese but none of us speak Chinese if
you go you don't speak Chinese and you
memorize the book in Chinese word for
word letter for letter that is a
miracle you see what I'm saying that's
one of the miracle of the Quran that
Allah made it easy to be mized so so so
that's why like I said we believe in the
same God however I have the Bible
here this is the
Bible when the Bible you can see many
passages in the Bible which is speaks
about God in a bad way okay you
understand and that doesn't mean I
reject everything in the Bible there is
some truth in it you understand like I
said so so the Quran came to clarify the
truth to us you know so we believe in
the same God in reality however like I
said the the true fls of Jesus they
never believed in
Trinity they never even Jesus himself
his own mother never believed in fre God
his own mother she never believed Jesus
was God right yes like in the Bible she
never said my baby is my God she never
you understand so so when to that's why
what distinguish Islam from any religion
first Islam is not connected to any
human being what do you want
by what do you what do I mean by that
Hindu Buddhism to Buddha Christianity to
Christ Judaism to Judah Islam means
submit yourself to
God yes Prophet Muhammad came to teach
us how to worship God Like Jesus Moses
Abraham Noah Jacob Isaiah but we are
Islam means submission to God according
to his teaching you understand
so so when you look at God's teaching
when you look to uh uh uh uh Islamic
teaching it goes in line with the sound
lening you are here for a purpose and
God created everything based upon God's
wisdom and mercy and Justice God send
the prophets and messenges to teach us
how to worship him and tell us this life
is a test you know let me give you
example but before we move on so far
does he make sense that there's a
creator for the
universe yeah I follow that yeah alhamd
of course without any doubt like you
know you know Subhan Allah there's a
chapter in the Quran called insan which
means human being so Allah said I'll
mention the verse translate for you
Allah
said the meaning of the verse Allah said
is it not the time for human being to
think deeply once upon a time there were
not even word of mentioning and now and
we have created and now you can hear and
you can see and we have created from a
mix sperm and and the Egg and so on yeah
so the point here is
that imagine from a sperm and an egg you
come and I come and we have hearing we
have a sight we have sight we have
hearing we have we have Consciousness
it's a miracle go god mentioned that in
the Quran you know so so like I said to
you when God in the Quran told us about
his creation to reflect and that he the
Creator he used which we call Universal
proofs to establish there is a Creator
and by the way the Creator or believ in
God is something which is well rooted
within us however due to due to our
environment sometimes we divert from it
okay I explain to you you know there was
a study in Oxford University there it
took them three years all right so they
spent 1.9 million on this study yeah and
um so they took children from different
part of the world so they came to know
children if you leave them alone they
will grow up as believing there's God
and there's a purpose for life and you
know what is interesting the prophet
Muhammad our Prophet Muhammad was was
the prophet the messenger of everyone he
said that for 1,400 years ago he said
every newborn is born with a f f in
Arabic mean natural inclination that
naturally they are born to believe in
God to be a Muslim why do you why do I
why do I mean by that to be a Muslim
doesn't mean he knows there's a prophet
called Muhammad God's name is Allah no
he's born with u with natural Nation to
recognize the Creator and to know that
he should be worshiped alone and should
be grateful to his creator so however
his family make him a Jew or a Christian
or a fire worshipper you know that's why
in Islam Allah will never punish people
until the proof has been established
upon them okay imagine like someone from
per in the middle of nowhere in per
Algeria he never heard about Islam and
then he dies on the day of Resurrection
Allah will test him CU Allah mentioned
the
Quran Allah will never the meaning of
the verse Allah will never punish people
until the proof has reached them you
understand so so when you look at Islam
like I said it goes in line with our
sound reasoning our natural inclination
what the Miracle of Islam is well the
Quran I mentioned that also Prophet
Muhammad prophecies Prophet Muhammad he
mentioned it will come a time you know
interest interest yeah interest will
become
widespread interest will become
widespread even if you are not involved
directly will affect you just let us
remember Prophet
Muhammad existed 1,400 years ago during
his lifetime there was no lot of
interest I mean look what he said he
said even if you are not involved
directly will affect you now by
therefore if you open a bank account
your money is been used for interest
even if you go to them tell them listen
I don't want to use I don't want no
interest in my account but they still
use it you see so look at this subh
Allah this mean glory be to God yeah
also there's another prophecy Prophet
Muhammad said it will come a time when
you see the barefooted Arab man the
barefooted Arab man bedw
they will start competing in build T
buildings when the prophet Muhammad
mentioned back in those days the Arabs
were not known to build tall buildings
those who were known the Persians and
the Romans let me ask you where is the
tallest building in the world that's
Dubai Dubai bro who's competing with
them now Saudi right so again bro how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago
prophesizing about things which we can
observe right now because why that
prophet he told he's a messenger of the
most high and no one knows about the
future in details except the creator of
everything you know what I'm saying it
makes sense it does yeah no doubt so
I'll give you another one about Islam
Islam came to preserve five things Islam
came to preserve five things which we
call it Universal necessity if we do
preserve these five things we'll have
good Society Islam came to preserve
religion what does that mean it means in
Islam worshiping the true God and
following the true teaching God is so
important that's why Islam paganism
politicism atheism AGN agnosticism is
forbidden why because it turns you away
from your Creator and when you turn away
from your creator by Def you start
following your own desires and when we
start following our own desires we can't
see what's happening now people are
confused man is confused if it's a woman
woman confused to be a man you know
children are confused cuz why they said
everything is subjective basically
there's no absolute truth so we just
have for our desires so that's why it's
so important Islam to keep the Islamic
teaching pure you understand because
that will protect us second thing Islam
came to preserve
intellect that's why Islam alcohol and
drugs
forbidden thirdly Islam came to preserve
uh wealth that's why gambling and
interest is forbidden right gambling
interest yeah cuz gambling G what is
gambling gambling you are losing money
like sometimes people go and steal from
their own kids their own wives their own
parents phones and everything and they
sell it just for the sake to play
gambling you know destroy Society
families likewise interest interest make
the rich richer poor poorer interest is
slavery in Islamic teaching if you are
in need then I should help you I should
not utilize your need to manipulate you
that's why Islam who have something
called Brotherhood and a Sisterhood
which is like a family and Prophet
Muhammad taught us he said we are like
one body the the Islamic nation is like
one body if any part of the body feel
pain the rest of the body feel pain
that's why sometimes you see see Muslims
getting angry and frustrated what's
happened in Palestine because they are
brothers even we are far away from each
other but our brothers and sisters you
know so likewise Islam came to preserve
uh lineage or Heritage that's why
fornication adultery is forbidden cuz
when you fornicate adul
firstly if you really love a woman marry
her you know and when you fornicate what
happened after that you can't just leave
her she has no right over you how many
children been killed abortion because
woman should sleep around or you can't
blame the woman all the time like like a
man manipulates a woman but when you
want to have intercourse of us the woman
say wait let's go to our parents and get
married you understand that's why
Prophet Muhammad said if you really love
a woman marry her you know so so
likewise Islam came to present life
that's why Islam killing people unjustly
and committing suicide and harming
yourself is forbidden so these five
things if we do preserve them we have
good Society what is the other one the
opposite like we mentioned alcohol drugs
gambling interest fornication and the
most evil one which is what we need turn
away from God cuz all of this stuff we
do it because are following our own
desires and Satan you know and that's
why majority of times those who are very
hostile to Islam either are ignorant or
those who are in power and those who are
in power and authority they are making
money from the poor from the people
suffering like through interest gambling
and so on so they're going to look at
Islam as a threat for their
business so what they're going to do
they're going to utilize their wealth to
make Islam look bad even though Islam is
good for us individually and
collectively the question that we should
ask ourselves how a man that existed
1,000 400 years ago was able who
couldn't read and write Prophet Muhammad
couldn't read and write you know he was
able to come with this a perfect way of
life you know because he's a messenger
of God and when God legislates something
there's no evil desires involved there's
no bias involved and when human
legislate something always there evil
desires for example there's off license
on the corner there you know there's off
license that corner there literally now
if someone is a drug dealer dealer and
he goes there next to the shop and he
start selling drugs he will get
arrested by the shopkeeper of off lies
nothing will happen to him even though
they are selling the same they are
selling both them are selling a product
that cause the same
harm rather alcohol is
worst so why we not arresting the
shopkeeper of off license but we are
arresting the drug dealer even though
they selling a product that cause the
same harm rather because why people
follow their desires cuz alcohol they
making a lot of money from it you know L
ta big tax high
taxes likewise I can give you another
example when you turn away from God
following our own desires we fall into
contradiction for example if you go to
schools colleges universities they teach
you don't get into gangs life you know
don't don't get don't stop people don't
carry knives gun and so on but on the
other hand they invite singers who
glorifies this lifestyle the lifestyle
of fornication the lifestyle of uh
crimes the lifestyles of of what they
call it gang's life and so on confusion
you see and they're getting paid with
ridiculous money so they're getting paid
more than the doctors who save people's
lives by Allah's permission that's why
the Islamic way is so perfect because it
comes from Allah tala Islam is perfect
but we as a Muslims we're not
perfect does he make sense so far what I
mentioned is it clear to you I actually
my Metro my my my but thank you really
let me give you a subject to read please
before you go cuz I wanted to read you
know uh this one take this one which is
steeven here take this but it very nice
talking to you but please look into it
we every Friday because you already have
to go but we every Friday if you want to
come and talk to us inah all right take
care of yourself thank you very much
take care
bye